Years
is upon us,
so we're going to be doing a little
progress report here.
I hope you guys had a chance to check
out my interview from last week with
Peter Boghossian.
For those of you that might have missed
it.
My intention with Peter was to focus on
atheism as well as critical thinking.
These are ideas that Peter wrote his
book about,
spends most of his time talking about
and are obviously topics that I'm
interested in.
I think at about 13 questions prepared
for Peter,
but like many of my interviews,
the conversation pretty much just took a
life of its own and last week's case
though,
something particularly interesting
happened no matter how far I tried to
steer the conversation away from the
regressive left and I tried many times.
All roads kept leading back to them.
I've mentioned to you guys a couple
times now how I want to talk about all
kinds of things on this show from
science to politics to spirituality and
much more.
I've also mentioned to you guys how I
don't want to solely focus on the
regressive left primarily because it
doesn't necessarily solve anything.
Still.
I find myself incredibly torn about this
topic on one hand until the last couple
months,
we hadn't even diagnosed the problem of
the regressive left,
right?
Clearly huge numbers of those of you on
the left were upset about how your team
was being hijacked,
but there wasn't a place to come
together and talk about it,
much less a whole group of likeminded
people willing to share their
experiences and tell their stories.
For that reason,
I've wanted to keep this conversation
going.
It's important to realize how many of us
are actually out there.
There are a lot we want to fix the left,
but I don't think we can without getting
to critical mass on the issue.
On the other hand,
I don't sense that we can actually
change these regressives.
As I've also mentioned before,
since we've started doing the show,
I've seen these guys continue to lie and
smear opponents only to be caught and
then doubled down or even more.
Some people are fighting back against
these lies with facts and logic.
Fortunately,
I've had several of these people on the
show,
like my new eyes,
Sarah Hater,
and God said,
others I know only from the online space
such as my guest this week,
Ali Rizvi Ali's,
an atheist Muslim who's constantly
writing about and fighting against
regressive ideology growing up mainly in
Saudi Arabia and ultimately leaving
religion for secularism.
He should be a natural hero of the left.
Sadly,
he's not a.
that's one of the many things that we're
going to talk about.
I go back and forth between thinking
that fighting the regressives by putting
time and energy into discussing them is
what will ultimately do the most to
change the landscape of the left and
then just thinking that if we ignore
them,
maybe they'll go away.
I tend to think that most of you will
tell me that we have to keep amplifying
real liberal voices and that by ignoring
them will only let their influence grow.
That's pretty much what I think too.
I must say that I'm incredibly inspired
by the fact that half the time when I
see anything that they write,
tweet or whatever,
there's an army of people ready to
combat their bullshit.
A few people have mentioned to me that
they believe that this whole regressive
situation and the fuel it gives to the
right is only gonna get worse before it
gets better.
Unfortunately,
I think these people are probably
correct until the real,
legitimate,
true voices of liberalism can come back
to the forefront.
This conversation is always going to be
stuck between the regressives and the
trumps.
It looks like we've got our work cut out
for us for 2016.
My guest this week is Ali Rizvi.
Allie writes for the Huffington Post and
his first book,
the atheist Muslim losing my religion,
but not my identity is being published
in 2016.
He's a strong advocate for the
advancement of secularism and science,
particularly in the Muslim world.
Allie,
welcome to the show.
Uh,
Dave,
glad to be on.
So we've been doing this as I start
almost all my shows by saying that the
guests,
we've been doing this on twitter for a
while and you are another one of these
anti regressive warriors.
So I'm happy that you're joining me this
week.
Yeah,
you can,
you can't help but be.
I mean it's just uh,
doing anything like this.
It's almost synonymous.
Yeah,
it,
it absolutely is.
So.
All right,
we're gonna.
We're gonna.
Talk a little bit about the regressives
of course,
but let's,
let's talk about you first.
I want people to understand sort of who
you are,
where you come from a,
you spent most of your youth up until
your early teens in Saudi Arabia.
Is that right?
Right.
I did.
So I pretty much grew up there.
I was born and then after that we moved
to Tripoli in Libya.
Lived there for several years and then I
went to Saudi Arabia where I was
actually until high school.
And then after that I went back to
Boston again for a university and then
came to Canada.
So why were you bouncing around so much?
My parents are professors and they liked
going in different places and they,
they,
you know,
they got really good job.
Offers are both very,
very competent and uh,
so they've traveled all over the place.
Yeah.
So those are just the countries we lived
in and you know,
we used to visit all over the place.
So just generally when it comes to North
Africa and the Middle East and South
Asia seen a lot of places growing up.
Well interestingly,
all three of those,
particularly Pakistan and Libya are
probably extremely different now than
they were when you were there.
Olivia.
I don't have too many.
I mean that's when we lived there when I
was a kid,
so I don't have,
I do have strong memories of it,
but uh,
they're probably not representative at
all by the way it is right now.
And in Pakistan is also very different
than it used to be and I haven't been
there for a while now.
I can't go there.
So.
Right.
So,
uh,
we'll talk about why you can't go there
in a little bit,
but let's talk about Saudi Arabia for a
bit because it's such an important
player in world politics and its
relationship to the United States.
And I feel like people actually know
very little about Saudi Arabia,
the nature of our relationship.
What was it like growing up there?
Your parents as professors obviously
came from the,
I'm assuming that was middle class,
sort of educated middle class.
Well,
how did that relate to
religion and secularism and all that?
It was,
um,
it was,
it was complicated.
So the way I describe it as my own
nuclear family,
like my parents and my siblings are sort
of a liberal,
progressive type of Shia Muslim family.
And so we had that.
And then outside that I was in the
private American school,
the American International School in
Riyadh,
the time.
So the school was obviously,
it was American,
so we had an American textbooks.
We listen to American music and uh,
you know,
I mean it wasn't,
it was an American school but had people
from about 80 different nationalities
that.
So it was a truly international school,
um,
and then the,
outside of that,
when we stepped out of that,
it was,
you know,
cover your hair.
Women can't drive,
you know,
five times prayer and if you're outside
during the prayer,
you know,
you'll get caught by one of the baton
was they call them,
which is the religious police.
So it was strange seeing all of these
three things.
But when,
you know,
when you're growing up with something as
a kid that is normal for you,
that's what you think everything's like.
So I actually think that it was a good
thing to be exposed to all of those
worlds at the same time.
So I was uh,
you know,
when,
for instance,
when nine slash 11 happened,
uh,
I could,
you know,
the Saudis coming in from there.
And I remember the mentality that there
was,
there was one thing I described in my
book is a,
when I was in fifth grade at the
American school,
we'd made paper snowflakes out of you
fold up a piece of paper,
you cut snowflakes and we decorated them
with glue and glitter and our names.
And we were happy,
I was about 10 years old and uh,
it was,
even though it was an American school,
the Saudi Ministry of Education used to
send an inspector once in a while to
make sure everything's okay,
everything's going according to the
rules.
And he came in and he actually cut the
tips off of each of the snowflakes,
was very angry and cut them off and we
asked our teacher what was going on so I
can know what is this.
And then she told us about the Star of
David and why we can everything that has
six points that sort of symbolizes that.
And that was our whole class of 10 year
olds.
That was our introduction,
at least my introduction to the Jews.
Right.
So,
um,
and this was just a spot check from an
inspector,
but their kids,
it's hard to will go to the Saudi
schools.
They have the stuff in their textbooks.
The guy who did that spot check for us
was actually,
he actually writes the curriculum for
the rest of them.
So when nine slash 11 happened and I saw
that kind of culture,
those people coming in from there and
then the people in my school,
like the Americans,
they're the ones being attacked over
here.
It was,
it was really strange seeing it because
I've kind of grown up with both sides in
parallel,
you know,
the,
and all my teachers were American and a
lot of my friends were from the US and
Canada.
On the other hand,
the company I was living in was a place
while the hijackers came from.
So at fifth grade.
So you're probably,
I guess that's about 11 years old or so.
Um,
was that sort of,
were your secular awakening?
Was,
was happening,
is that the time of that or how
religious was your family?
Were you,
were you guys away from it already or
break that down for me?
Well,
my family was,
my family was sort of liberal,
religious.
I mean,
there were Muslim,
they were believing Muslims.
We used to go through the,
you know,
we did the Ramadan thing.
We used to go where she,
we to do tomorrow morning.
Uh,
my parents used to prey on and off,
but usually they made it to like two or
three times a day on average.
Um,
so,
you know,
they were,
there must be an interesting diagram of
people praying and then the sort of
dropoff as it gets later in the day.
Right.
There is,
I,
I don't know,
a lot of them Muslims,
you actually believe pray five times a
day.
Every time I watch TV and uh,
it's,
you know,
this is a slight tangent,
but every time you know,
you google,
North American,
Muslim or American Muslim,
you'll get a whole picture of people
with head scarves and you know,
people in mosques and so on.
But they're just,
as a representative of us Muslims is,
as you know,
any modes and group care and Islam or
not,
what is exactly why we should all be
talking to people like you more because
I have no faith that the media is giving
us examples of any,
forget religion,
ethnicity,
whatever it is.
The media gives us such bad examples of
everybody that that's why we have to
talk to the outliers.
Right.
And you understand it in a way,
and I'm sorry we're going away from your
original question.
That's fine.
Yeah,
I understand it in a way because you
know,
for instance,
if there's something,
some story relating to Christianity,
you're not exactly going to call it
pastor or you know,
somebody who's a was a,
a priest or something like that is an
expert in Christianity.
But um,
the thing with Muslims as it's different
when you think Jerry Seinfeld with David
Letterman,
you don't think jus right?
But with right,
well I don't think letterman's Jewish,
but I think either way
I thought he was a comedian so it's
close enough.
Comedian is a whole different.
That's a separate.
I think that's another thing.
But um,
you know,
when you,
when,
when it comes to Muslims,
I mean Dave Chappelle,
Dr Oz,
Shaq o'neal,
like all of these guys.
I mean these are people who are Muslim,
but that's not who you say that,
that's not the representation.
Even though they're right here in front
of our faces.
So when,
when you see it on tv,
it's always the one with the headscarf.
Every,
almost every non Muslim I know who works
with the Muslim of work has gone for a
beer with them afterwards.
You know,
a lot of people have dated Muslim girls
and they've very few of them actually
wear the headscarf.
But
I'm pretty sure if,
uh,
if Shaq was the main representative for
Muslim,
things would be extremely different
right now.
You wouldn't,
they probably probably for the better.
Um,
so,
so tell me a little more.
So your family.
So you guys were sort of religious but
not that religious.
You were getting some of this at school,
but that was obviously Americanized a
right.
Keep going.
I mean,
my,
my main,
the first time is truly skeptical of
that religion.
And God was when I was five years old
and I actually had a cousin and she was
three and this is said that she lived in
London and she had childhood leukemia.
So,
you know,
she was close to my age.
I was five.
She was three,
you know,
we were playmates and uh,
when she was dying,
everybody who came into the room,
so this was like an art in the culture,
you know,
last moments every once in those kids
where they're there and it's a,
if you know what a child's death,
especially from cancer,
it's absolutely horrific.
So cancer doesn't discriminate.
Same amount of pain and adult fields is
what a three year old child would feel.
So print at that time there wasn't
really any good cure for childhood,
acute lymphoblastic leukemia either.
So at that point my mother and my aunt
were praying and crying and I was
standing there with my father and I
asked my father,
I'm like,
you know,
what's going on?
And I was watching her in pain and he
said that God's taking her back,
you know,
God's taking her to a better place and
keeping her with him.
So I'm thinking,
okay,
that's not such a bad thing.
So why are they crying and why they
praying so hard and they're like,
they're,
they're begging God not to take her
away.
They want him to,
you know,
like stop the pain or not take away and
to me like in my mind we used to play
tug of war at school,
so I was thinking of the tug of war game
where there's this God who's all
powerful apparently and we're on the
other end and we're pulling it.
It just seemed like a very sadistic
thing to do.
It also,
it also sounds like such a losing
proposition if you're the believer,
so if in this case your,
your,
your father,
assuming he was a believer or or that
maybe he was just playing the role as a
father,
but it's a losing proposition if you
pretty much know medically that the
child is not going to make it and yet
you have these people praying and you
know the outcome is pretty much in
front.
What are you actually saying about
prayer is also an interesting angle.
I mean that's the other thing.
I think that if the of God is all
powerful and there's a three year old
kid in pain,
you don't find.
I understand,
you know,
you have to take the kid back then don't
like don't draw it out,
don't drop the agony cause of cancer
deaths are terrible.
We,
you know,
at that point that the clarity of a five
year old mind,
I obviously that I remember this very
clearly.
It's one of my earliest strongest
memories just because of the intensity
of it.
And after that I thought it was like,
okay,
nobody's really going to be happy with
this God character anymore,
but the next week or every ritual,
everything got was a hero.
You know,
everyone who's continued praying to him.
So it didn't make a lot of sense to me.
And then after that I thought I was like
maybe,
well all these guys,
you know,
all the adults grown ups think it makes
sense.
Or maybe I'm the WHO's crazy,
but then I'd see I'd watched TV and
there'd be a disaster,
natural disaster,
a tornado or a flood or something,
and the lone survivor or two would say,
no,
I'm God bless.
God saved me.
I'm so thankful to God knows.
I'd always think know what did the other
people do,
so as a kid it was always there and then
I dabbled in and out of being religious
to some extent,
like whenever had exams final.
Is that.
Well,
that's where the prayer would kick in.
Yeah.
So it was,
it was like my cousin used to call the
bing God reviving God.
He was a very religious guy.
God probably took your brides.
I'm guessing you were pretty good
student.
Yeah.
It turned out that I was fairly.
Yeah,
I did well in school.
Like I did,
turned out whether I prayed or not.
God somehow was okay with me.
But all those kids with HIV in Africa
somehow.
Yeah,
just somehow my grades were okay.
But HIV for the kids in Africa,
not so much.
Alright.
So you,
you have this awakening and it,
and it's happening now where,
where was the full,
sort of more adult version of your
awakening?
Were you still in Saudi Arabia or was
that,
uh,
when you had left already?
I had,
I had left.
I had gone,
gone to medical school at that point in
Pakistan.
I finished,
I'd completed it,
and towards the end of it I had a
actually really started reading.
Um,
the,
uh,
well I'd started reading the Scripture
and everything,
the Koran when I was much younger,
but I think when the internet came
around and I wanted to do more research,
I was able to find more things.
So this was around 99 or something.
I was already in my twenties.
I'm a,
I'm a little up there.
So yeah.
So I started,
uh,
you know,
when I actually started reading it,
then when people got more and more
defensive about it,
the more I talked to,
especially in practice,
then when you talk to people,
they give you all of these responses.
Like,
you know,
those aren't true,
Muslims are,
you know,
this is sort of a bit of peace or that
thing that you're recording from the
crime that's mistranslated or
misinterpreted or it's a metaphor or
whatever the excuse was gonna.
Eventually it started seeing through it
and then I think it was actually one day
when it hit me.
I'm like,
this,
I shouldn't have given considering this.
I mean,
this is a guy lived inside a fish.
You know,
there's,
it says it says in its.
I'd hear that in the Koran.
For me it was a karate for a lot of
people.
It's a bible and everything,
but
by the way,
we should note that they're all equally
crazy.
There's plenty of evil stuff and all of
them we want,
you know,
we want to be good liberals here,
so let's not pile on one right.
There is plenty of awful stuff in the
Old Testament.
Sure.
They always say that if Moses hadn't
hallucinated up the Old Testament,
then you know,
Muhammad couldn't have plagiarized it.
It is an and there's a lot of
similarities as a no pork.
There's no for,
for miles,
there's a Shalom and Salaam and then
both of their nicknames are mow it in a
way.
There's a,
you know,
there are a lot of similarities between,
especially between Judaism and Islam and
the violence and the books.
It's absolutely.
I mean that's a,
that's an obvious thing,
but I used to think of like,
what are you doing when people would
quote a 4:34
which says that you can beat your wife
if your disobedience as a last resort
and they justify it now like,
well no,
it actually means this or it's only as a
last resort.
And I used to think,
I'm like,
if I had written this in my book and the
book came out last week,
you guys would be killing me for this.
I mean there's the word you wouldn't be
looking for context.
You wouldn't be looking at alternative
interpretations.
That's a luxury that we only afford two
holy books and we don't read Alice in
wonderland that way.
So you know,
the and the,
you know,
people like,
for example,
Reza and so on will be like,
no,
this is,
we should not read this.
Literally like the worst thing is that
people will read it.
Literally.
I was actually on a,
on a show.
I was on the agenda with Steve here in
Toronto and I was sitting next to
Shabbir Ali,
who who's an Islamic scholar,
and at one point he actually said,
he's like,
look,
people misquote the Koran by quoting it.
Literally.
I was just thinking that that was one of
the most amazing sentences,
if that's a great quote right there.
He's a great guy.
But he said it and I used to think,
I'm like,
I understand why they're so terrified of
people quoting it.
Literally any script,
because it's terrifying.
If you could,
if you quote those words exactly the way
that they're written are exactly the way
they were said by God,
apparently a,
then it's a terrifying thing,
you know.
So they say,
well,
you have to look at the interpreters and
the scholars and then you listen to the
scholars and they're saying these human
beings,
their explanations of what's God,
when God's word is actually means more
than what God's word is itself,
which again doesn't make any sense,
and Isis and al Qaeda and the Taliban,
um,
these are these people.
They're not quoting scholars.
I mean they're,
they're quoting scripture.
And recording the deed.
Yeah.
You know,
after the Paris attacks,
I got into it on twitter with one of my,
one of my friends on the left who were
immediately was,
you know,
with within wild the thing I think while
the event was still happening,
so literally they hadn't caught anybody
yet.
I mean there were bodies still on the
floor at the theater.
He immediately went to the American
foreign policy stuff and then a few
minutes after that they released the
guys who did it.
Isis actually released the statement and
there was a ton of scripture in there.
And I said,
well,
what do you think about this?
And then the conversation sort of
dwindled off into nothing and I.
and I think that's part of what this
whole schism here on the left that we've
been talking so much about is related
to,
you know,
like it's scripture,
it's written word that somebody is
believing and taking into action.
And then also there's a lot of messed up
foreign policy stuff by every country in
the world.
Yeah.
I
always find it.
I find it interesting that whenever I'm,
I'm debating or I'm having a discussion
with anybody,
usually if it's someone who is moderate
or someone or an academic or someone
else in Islamic studies for instance,
they don't want to talk about the
scripture and they're like,
well,
come on,
let's just not talk about the scripture
as if it's sort of beneath them.
It's like,
you know,
we're going to talk about the social
logical implications with this.
You know,
how does religion workout is ideal
identity formation and all of these
other things,
economics and so on.
But whenever I talked to a guy with a
beard,
you know,
someone who's more of a fundamentalist
and I like at times I'll sit and I said
this on the show to Shabbir Ali too.
I was like,
well,
let's not get into the whole scripture
thing,
but they almost always turned around and
say,
no,
that's what's important.
That's what religion is.
So the people who are actually believing
it and going along with the tenants of
it and actually following the example of
the prophet and so on.
These are people who actually take
scripture very,
very seriously at the rest of the people
don't and I think it's because there is
an element of rationality and then they
just can't believe.
They're like,
okay,
this is a book,
but nobody really believes this.
Yeah.
So last week my guest is Peter
Boghossian,
who you're probably familiar with and he
wrote a book called a manual for
creating atheists and one of the things
that I thought was most interesting
about it was that he basically said,
you know,
because these beliefs are not based in
critical thinking or rationality and
that people have to take this leap of
faith that actually if you can really
sit someone down and you do it sort of
with the right intent and,
and a clear mind,
you can start pulling the,
the underpinnings away in an effective
way and you can actually convert people
into free thinkers.
Uh,
I'm gonna Guess that you've done quite a
bit of that yourself.
The only reason I do what I do,
Dave,
is because of that.
Anytime somebody tells me,
it's like another way that you talk to
people.
It's not going to work,
people aren't going to change their
mind.
That is absolutely not true.
And I've got,
um,
you know,
if,
if you look at my inbox,
my email inbox,
like almost on a daily basis,
you know,
I get messages.
I mean the most recent one was not,
I don't know if you read that post at
one fire arrows by a friend of mine see
me Ramond and she wrote about the dead
telling the difference between a
moderate and radical.
She lives in California.
She's a pediatrician.
Um,
I'll,
I'll send it to you.
Yeah,
please do.
Yeah.
And she,
um,
so it went viral,
got thousands and thousands of shares
and so on.
And she got a message just a few days
ago and there was this a woman who
actually wore than the cop.
It was a very conservative family and
she'd read it.
And um,
she has now she's seriously thinking
about taking it off.
Like he was completely shaken the way
that she's thinking about things,
the way that she grew up.
And these are stories that I hear
everyday and I hear them more than ever
in Muslim majority countries.
And,
and this is what's so interesting is
that in North America generally lead to
the Muslims because they're,
they're used to,
uh,
the free speech and the open discourse
and everything.
Uh,
they are,
they like to have a respectful approach.
So like,
okay,
criticize religion to be respectful of
us.
They don't like the tone that somebody
like,
for example,
like Richard Dawkins or Bill Maher
takes.
However,
in the Muslim,
in these Muslim majority countries where
they're living under these sorts of a
theocratic dictatorships,
even though they're not officially a
almost all of them are,
um,
for them,
they,
that really resonates for them with them
to eat with a more aggressive tone
because they're oppressed by it.
They can't speak.
So they're angry.
They're frustrated.
The last person that they heard who
spoke went out and he got hacked to
death and in Daca.
And um,
so you know,
they,
they are,
they're angry and they're frustrated and
they,
they want that kind of talent.
They,
they feel like the respectful discourse
is the luxury of the privileged people
who are able to have values like freedom
of speech,
and then we can take that who take that
for granted.
That's really fascinating because,
you know,
I've talked a lot about how people,
especially it's Dawkins and Mara are the
two that have sort of become,
you know,
the most outspoken on atheism really.
And,
and talking about the doctrine of Islam,
I think they're pretty both pretty clear
that's out there in the Muslim majority
countries.
So.
Yeah.
But what I think,
what I think is interesting here is that
I hear from atheists will say,
well,
Dawkins,
Mr they're there to offense,
you know,
it's too offensive there'd be,
they're putting out too much and they're
not speaking in a friendly way.
So atheist or angry at them for being
atheist.
But interestingly you're saying that in
foreign places in foreign countries,
they need to hear it in that light.
And that's incredible.
Yeah.
Because they actually want to say it
that way.
I mean,
if you,
the most,
um,
sort of aggressive sounding atheists
that you'll meet from the Muslim world
are the ones who actually grew up.
They're the ones with the accents are
the ones who made it here after living
there who think that all Americans kind
of take freedom of speech and polite
discourse and so on for granted.
So they,
they are angry.
They want a more angry sort of,
uh,
um,
expression of it.
But there,
I mean,
there is a point,
I do understand why people,
different things work on different
people.
I always give the example of the civil
rights movement,
how,
you know,
Rosa parks acted in silence,
she was sitting on the,
on the bus and she said,
I'm not going to move back.
On the other hand,
Martin Luther King was the diplomat
know,
so he was,
um,
he was sort of more political.
He was conciliatory,
used to try to make a reasoned arguments
and talk to the other side.
On the other hand,
you had malcolm x who was a more
militant and all of those approaches had
had a role that a very key role in and
they work on different people.
Um,
my approach is probably more sort of,
uh,
I,
I tried to be reasonable.
I reasonable arguments.
I try to do that at least.
Um,
but um,
I do appreciate people who do the kind
of thing that Bill Maher and Richard
Dawkins soon because I know that it
resonates.
I know that it's a,
um,
it's a very satisfying to a lot of
people growing up there.
And I remember when I was growing up
there,
whenever I would hear people say things
like that.
And it was George Carlin at the time,
you know,
I,
um,
I remember seeing little things that
George Carlin had done and the way that
he talked about religion,
it was just so in your face.
And so like nakedly open some of it that
it was extremely satisfying to watch.
But that's something that you could not
see and,
and you'd,
you'd show it to your friends is on a
vhs tape and show to your friends and
then you know,
little clip where you said it and you
see the shock on their faces and it was,
it was something really satisfying about
it.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
I tell my friend,
Kelly Carlin,
who has been on the show,
who is George's daughter.
I tell Kelly literally once a week I'll
call her or text her and say,
God,
ironically,
I'll say,
gosh,
you know,
I really wish that your dad was around
now because we're so trapped and I think
this will get us to the next portion of
this conversation,
but we're so trapped in this pc world
right now and we're so afraid of
language and we're so afraid of
offending everybody.
And already,
as you've said,
sometimes you have to offend people to
actually break through.
It's not your style clearly.
Right?
Like you're not looking to offend
everybody,
but ended up doing it anyway.
I think that the nature of the.
But you know,
the thing is,
I'm like,
I hear this a lot,
I hear a lot of people say that,
especially a lot of my Muslim friends in
here living in the US and in Canada,
is that the free freedom of speech does
not mean the freedom of to offend.
And I always say to them,
I'm like,
there's no such thing as freedom of
speech without the freedom and offend
every.
There is absolutely no major
revolutionary change that has ever
happened in history that did not piss
off a lot of people.
So let's talk a little bit about our
friends on the left because,
uh,
I think they've,
they failed us,
but particularly you and your friends
and family probably in,
in this regard,
they have somehow align themselves with
forces that don't want you to speak up
against doctrine.
And I,
and that's really incredible.
It's the reverse of liberalism and I'll
let you take it from there.
Well,
I mean,
that's what I think.
I think if you're against bad ideas,
bad ideas anywhere,
if you oppose homophobia,
homophobia is a terrible thing.
It should be a bad thing.
And,
you know,
you pointed out every time it's someone
caused the Bible or every time it's in a
donald trump's speech,
um,
you know,
or to Ted Cruz speech or whatever it is,
then that's team idea is also a bad idea
when it's in the Koran and if it's being
said by Muslims,
including a lot of liberal Muslims,
I mean,
that is something that even a lot of
liberal Muslims in North America haven't
warmed up to yet.
So these,
um,
I understand like there's the,
I think there's a certain instinct to
try and protect the minority,
uh,
but the ideology that the minority here
subscribes to just coincidentally,
and I'm not saying that they follow it
the same way that they do in other more
violent parts of the world,
but that same ideology,
the same book is being used to kill
people,
right?
And to throw gay people off rooftops in
other parts of the world.
So I think it's,
it is very confusing for everybody
because you know,
the way that it happens is people see
here,
especially non Muslims,
they see on tv,
they see a group called the Islamic
state quoting the Koran accurately and
actually seeing quoting verses that say
fight the disbelievers and charge them,
you know,
at the Non Muslim tax and you know,
God will destroy them and so on.
So they're quoting these verses,
they're saying a lot whopper,
right?
So they're,
they're obviously professing their faith
and then they're chopping someone's
heads off or throwing somebody off a
rooftop.
And the reaction over here often when
they see that is that they immediately
jumped in defending the faith that this
is the real faith.
And the moment they say that,
you know,
do bring the scripture to them.
You're like,
well what about this verse?
They quote just like you did with your
friend,
you know,
what about this versus that?
They quoted this to says exactly the
words that they said here,
match the action,
and then they start defending the verses
and the book a misinterpretation out of
context.
And so on.
All the,
you know that sort of the excuses that
you're here and so now what you have is
you have moderate Muslims here.
I'm defending the same book that the
fundamentalists over there are quoting
and citing to kill non Muslims over
there that the non Muslims are looking
at this side of the world and that is
toxic because it actually makes.
That gives the impression the moderate
Muslims over here are pretty much that
they subscribed to the same ideology.
They're just not acting on it,
which is not true,
but that's impression of gifts.
Not only is it not true,
but it seems to me that people like you,
people like my new eyes,
Sarah Haider,
great people in my estimation,
who I think are fighting for the right
things,
who are applying the same principles
across the board.
They're not looking at your faith or
your race or your nationality.
They're saying,
here are humanistic principles,
right?
That I want to apply to everyone.
The left is the one attacking them.
Did you ever expect that that was going
to be the push back for you?
For me,
I know I didn't honestly.
Well,
I mean,
I knew that there were a lot of sort of
moderate Muslims that wouldn't have
problems with it.
I just didn't think that,
uh,
the,
the sort of these cj wellman's and the,
you know,
I guess whatever we call the regressive
left.
Um,
Dave,
I can't keep track of all of them.
So this is just the one for most recent
memory,
but the list on the side of your bed,
I have a chalkboard and I've just always
adding to the list.
You don't have that.
I can't,
I have,
I have better things to do.
I don't have enough time or crayons,
students,
lots of bumps.
I am spending a fortune in shock.
It's ridiculous.
No,
but the thing with the regressive left
on a serious note is there they're
reacting to,
you know,
the pushback that we're getting is a
reaction.
And for them I,
I just look at that entire thing is a
very,
very reactionary thing.
Their only argument,
the only argument they have to anything
as big an Islamophobe House,
Muslim or uh,
you know,
the Brown skinned white,
I don't know what it was.
Yeah.
So there's that,
that's the only argument that they have.
And I,
I,
I'm actually encouraged,
I'm optimistic about it.
I mean,
if you looked at in the past,
every time one of these attacks happened
and there was some conversation to be
taking place on tv about it on CNN or
msnbc or Fox or anything,
it would always be Reza Aslan who would
come on or they'd call,
you know,
the comedian guy,
uh,
on CNN deemed so him.
And so they would,
you know,
they'd,
that that's what they would do.
But now I'm not seeing that.
So,
you know,
since,
um,
these new attacks and now that
everything is getting even more serious,
you know,
I'm seeing more of Majid on TV.
I'm seeing more of US trying to Monte on
TV.
Um,
you know,
I'm seeing voices like this.
I'm seeing Ayaan Hirsi Ali being called
on to talk about things.
So I,
I think that most of the,
even the so called mainstream media is
seeing through it.
A Bill Maher actually said on the last
show that he was on or the one with us
when he interviewed her.
He actually said that he's more and more
liberals are coming up to an agreement
with them.
They used to get a lot of crap from him
before,
but he doesn't anymore.
And I think that that's changing and I
think that this whole,
what we call the regressive left is
simply responding to them.
Well,
I got to tell you,
I mean that sounds incredibly uplifting
because,
you know,
I'm,
I'm so in this and having these
conversations and as I said at the top
of the show,
I find a lot of it exhausting and I
battled sort of between back and forth
of like,
can I move on from this topic?
And every time I move on I feel like I
get sucked back in and you know,
I'll,
I'll put it away and then I'll suddenly
see your,
your twitter fight with someone or I'll
see,
you know,
Greenwald attacking Sam or whatever it
is.
But I think you gave me a little
something to go with there because the
idea that they are acting out more.
It's getting more like a,
a child having a tantrum.
And maybe it's just because they realize
this is the last vestige of an ideology
that's just not gonna work because
we've woke up,
right?
Yeah.
I think that there are there prodding
basically for a response and we give it
to them,
you know,
in all honesty.
A lot of times I'll ignore it for
awhile.
And I,
and I,
I,
uh,
you know,
like with,
um,
I'll ignore it for very long time,
but if I do decide to respond to decide
response strong and it usually the
response is not for the person making
it.
It's for the rest of the audience,
for everybody else who's watching the
conversation.
I mean,
I,
I'm under no illusions that I can,
I can change the minds of a lot of these
sort of hacks on,
uh,
that,
that a lot of the trolls that actually
tried to dissuade us and trying to
deflect everything.
But,
um,
I think that for the wider audience who
seen the conversations,
it's good for them to see what they're,
what they're dealing with,
to see both sides of it.
And to see that play out,
you know,
on whether on social media or in books
or in articles and so on.
So I,
I think that,
you know,
the,
I'll give you,
I think that they're reacting to,
for instance,
with Sam Harris.
Sam Harris has a lot of great ideas.
He started a lot of really good
conversations,
in fact,
everything that we're seeing right now
with the rise of Donald Trump.
And so the hijacking of this
conversation by the sort of Xeno phobic
paranoid side and now them gaining
ground and capitalizing on the,
on the fear and the concern and the
confusion that everybody's feeling,
um,
something that the left should have
done,
but they didn't do right.
And they should have done it from a sort
of a moral,
a honest,
a position.
And,
and now it's being done by the right
from a Suunto phobic bigoted position.
I'm at.
This is something that Sam predicted a
long time ago that he wrote about it.
Um,
and now,
uh,
I,
I think,
you know,
what's happening is that,
this,
all of these spots back and forth with
the green walls and the world and you
know,
all of these other sort of characters
and they're deflecting from what was
initially that the actual thing that was
causing this response in the first
place.
Can you go ahead,
sorry.
Oh No,
I was just saying we should continue
what exactly what we were doing before
is what we should be doing.
We should just be talking about the
ideas.
I'm sticking to the big picture.
I mean,
I came from when I,
when I came here to Canada and to the US
after living for 24 years and enlisted
majority countries.
I wanted to bring,
I want to talk about big ideas,
you know,
I wasn't really concerned about
microaggressions or progressive left or
you know,
all of these other issues.
I actually wanted to talk about the big
ideas and,
and uh,
I've noticed that the more,
a lot of us over here are,
you know,
there are people who try to pull us into
these more sort of petty Jerry Springer
like conversations and I think it would
serve us best.
Just ignore it.
Yeah.
Well listen,
I'm doing my best to
do that and I know I'm saying that it's
especially after what happened last
week,
so I'm with me as well once in a while
or what,
once in a while I think you have to do
it and you have to look had all this
terrible stuff and all of the slandering
and all this stuff not happened.
Then I think the awakening,
it'll,
let's say you were awake probably before
I was.
I mean my real awakening to this
literally was that that night watching
real time with that athletic thing.
So had it not happened,
I may have been slumbering through,
you know,
the left going further and further to
the left.
So in a weird way,
it is actually very empowering,
but I,
that's actually a perfect segue to talk
about next,
which you're touching upon,
which is that by not dealing with this
in an honest fashion,
by not really allowing the people to
speak about it,
the liberals,
to speak about it in a fair way.
You're handing this to trump and we're
seeing this,
we're seeing this right now in America.
We're seeing this in Europe where for
the first time ever in places like
Sweden and Denmark far right parties are
running on anti immigration because it's
all wrapped up in.
Well,
we're afraid to be called racist.
So it's crazy,
right?
Yeah.
They're,
they're all,
everybody's Islamophobia,
phobic fear of being called a song
phobic.
And um,
yeah,
I think,
I think you're absolutely right.
I did.
We did in a way hand this to trump.
The problem over here is that there's.
Trump is not actually responsible for
all of this anti Muslim hate and all
this kind of time with some sentiment
that's happening.
So let's be clear on that,
that the party that's responsible for
that is the attackers,
the isis,
that people who would talk to Paris of
people who are making all these videos
of beheadings,
of journalists and so on.
I mean these are the people,
a debt the Americans and Westerners in
general are reacting to.
Right?
But wait,
let me stop you there because what would
you say to my friends on the left who
would say,
well,
it's America that created isis.
Well,
America,
there,
it's obviously a complicated thing,
you know,
US foreign policy or there's US foreign
policy.
There's nationalism,
there's greed,
there's power,
there's corporate corporatocracy and all
these other characters that people talk
about racism and misogyny.
And you were telling me that like,
why do you always pick on religion when
you have all of these factors?
And I,
I always turned around and I tell them,
I'm like,
I agree with you.
It didn't belong them right up there in
the same category with racism and greed
and misogyny and uh,
you know,
the terrible things that everybody else
is doing.
So I do think that US foreign policy is
a factor and the argument has never been
that a religion is the only caused a
religious sentiments.
He only caused the.
We're not asking people to recognize or
to think that it's not everything else
that's religion.
We're just saying that the only thing
that we're going against the idea that
it's everything but religion to ignore
the religious aspect of it or the fact
that beliefs actually have consequences
because we want to respect it.
So,
you know,
what I was saying earlier is that what
Donald trump is doing is that there is a
lot of confusion.
There's a lot of fear that a lot of
people have right now,
legitimately the way that you channel
that,
the way that leaders channel that is
what makes all the difference.
You know.
So Donald trump has basically fed off of
it.
He's drummed it up more for his own
opportunities,
this opportunistic purposes and these
turn into let's ban all Muslims.
Um,
if there was another reasonable voice,
you know,
on,
on the left,
and they had channeled that and they had
kind of responsibly dealt with it in an
honest way,
then we may see a different outcome
when,
when people are confused,
that's when leadership matters.
And that's where the liberals I think
failed.
So that,
that's interesting.
That naturally I,
I agree with that premise,
but I think you could really take it to
the candidates themselves.
So for example,
Bernie Sanders,
who I like a lot,
obviously,
and Hillary,
uh,
when you take the candidates that are on
the left,
that are the Democrats,
when they won't say Islamic extremism or
they won't say violent Jihad or
whatever,
whatever the term you want to,
you know,
everyone gets so caught up in terms that
I hate even using words at this point,
but when they won't even say the terms
and they'll just say religious extremism
or something,
I think that,
that they also then hand it to trump
because trump's just given you.
He's just given you the,
the wide,
wide net to go with and they're.
And they're still playing the games of
political correctness.
That's exactly that.
I completely agree that,
that is kind of what I was trying to say
is that they do it.
So there,
there are two things that have to be
done right now.
One is that the rights of Muslims have
to be protected,
and number two,
Islamic doctrine has to be challenged
and criticized.
Both of those things have to be done.
What the,
what the Hillary Clinton or Bernie
Sanders,
uh,
a site is doing is they're trying to
protect all the rights of Muslims
without actually challenging the
ideology.
And what the Donald Trump on the right
of these people are doing is that
they're challenging the ideology without
protecting the rights of the people.
And,
and it's not an undead.
People think that that's contradictory.
It's not contradictory at all.
This is what I think it was voltaire who
said,
right?
Like,
I,
I will,
I may despise what you say,
but I'll defend to the death your right
to say it's the same principle.
Um,
and it's not that difficult to do if we
have a responsible leader who actually
does that.
I think that that is something that a
lot of people would relate to and they
would understand that,
okay,
we will challenge doctrine and a lot of
Muslims they'll get her like,
you know,
you're challenging my religion and this
is my identity because people
incorporate their beliefs into their
identity and the dialogue would be,
well,
yes,
you're a person.
We respect your right to believe what
you.
But you know,
these are ideas.
Ideas are different.
We're talking about the ideas.
We're not talking about you as a person.
Right?
So that if the,
if there was a political party that was
running a,
you know,
that said we're gonna throw gays off
roofs and we're going to stone women and
kill apostates,
you'd probably be against that political
party.
But as a religion,
as a religious doctrine,
it gets a little extra credit or
something.
That's it.
That's the thing.
Like there's a lot of it completely.
It would be completely strange things
that we do,
for example,
of neonatal circumcision,
like infant circumcision is one of those
things where,
you know,
we,
I mean,
my parents did it,
you know,
my siblings have done it to their
nephews and so on.
It's a very dense,
illegal.
You're not everybody does it,
but when you really think about it,
if there was,
if there was no religion behind it or as
I like to save Abraham didn't,
wasn't so fond of dickheads you would do
this would be child abuse.
You'd have pediatricians getting sued
for this.
All right,
so I,
I,
so I want to circle back a little bit to
the beginning of the conversation and
your history and your story for a second
because you identify as an atheist
Muslim.
Is that correct?
Well,
if he is Muslim,
was the title of my book doctrinally.
It can't be an atheist Muslim,
but the whole point of the book is to
talk about the incorporation of religion
into identity.
Uh,
so there are a lot of.
I mean what,
so I'll explain it this way.
When I first came here,
two years after I permanently moved to
permanently move to Canada is when the
nine slash 11 attacks happened.
And when that happened,
I,
you know,
I had this whole conversation in my
head,
you know,
was part of a Muslim family.
I grew up with Muslim people.
I,
it,
I was in all the Muslim traditions.
They at that Ramadan,
the,
a lot of things are cultural.
They're reasonably cultural,
but there's some sort of Muslim things
like Ramadan.
So in doing so that was all a part of
me,
but at the same time I wasn't a huge fan
of the ideology.
Um,
so when I,
when I came here,
the 9:11
attacks happened.
This whole conversation that had been
going on in my head for a very long time
suddenly exploded and it was all going
on on TV.
It was on the radio is everywhere.
And there were two sides to it.
There was sort of the,
the,
the liberal side.
And they said that,
you know,
Muslims must be protected as a minority.
So any criticism of Islam is bigotry.
And on the right it was that.
And this is the sort of the Fox News
narrative was that Islam is a sort of
an,
it's a,
it's a violent religion,
so Muslims,
you know,
we need to profile everybody,
we need to clamp down on immigration,
you know,
all of those things.
And there was one mistake both of them
were doing is they were conflating the
ideology with the people putting the
ideology with the identity and this and
this is where I wish actually a middle
ground and I think what we're seeing,
we're seeing the same thing with the
regressive left on one side.
And you know,
the,
the Donald trump phenomenon on the other
is the same thing as the completion of
this,
uh,
sort of ideology and people invite by
people,
I mean people who are a Muslim Muslim
just because it's as a birth identity
because most people are Muslim because
it's just a birth.
That identity.
Right.
So for you personally,
while you're obviously an atheist,
so you're a nonbeliever,
do you,
are you culturally Muslim?
Like what does that actually mean to you
at this point?
Like,
I assume your family probably does some
holiday stuff,
maybe you don't believe in it,
but do you culturally identify the way
for me,
for example,
I am an atheist,
I am not a believer,
but there are Jewish traditions that my
family that my grandparents did that
their grandparents did,
their grandparents did that my family
does,
so I can do that and I,
and it doesn't have a religious
connotation.
It has a cultural connotation to me.
That's it.
That's exactly what it is.
I mean,
I enjoy not enjoy the FISA.
Ramadan Ramadan's a great time.
You people fasting.
I don't necessarily fast but I'm there
for them.
It's a bit much and I like to eat
celebration so I like,
you know,
I have little nieces and nephews and
they all dress up and you know,
I get them gifts and so I enjoy that as
much as anybody I'm on,
I,
I'm very close to my family,
my nuclear family and my extended family
and a lot of them are believing Muslims
so I do take part in that.
Um,
but there was also another place where
it affects you.
For instance,
I read a story about this kid who was
called was beat up at school and
because,
uh,
and they said that she was an isis baby
or nicest kid and neither one of my
niece and um,
I don't want my niece to go through that
and I did like this whole thing that's
happening in the US right now,
you know,
I don't,
I don't want my.
And I've got,
I've got nieces and nephews in the U.
S too.
And you got.
So I don't want them to go through that.
It would be completely heartbreak.
I'd be devastated if I heard that,
uh,
my own niece went through something like
that just because she has a Muslim name,
you know,
a Muslim sounding name.
She looks a certain way.
So it affects you at that level too.
So when things like that happen or you
know,
I,
I recently,
I recently posted about this.
I have a friend who's a physician.
Uh,
he's,
and he actually,
he's in California and he went to a
party recently and there was a woman who
came up to him and said,
you know,
you,
uh,
she called him a Taliban terrorists and
so on,
and she was a little drunk and
fortunately the people that he was
around,
uh,
jumped in and,
you know,
they defended him and they called her
out on it.
But,
uh,
these are things that are happening and
he's also an atheist by the way.
So he's from a Muslim background and you
know,
so when things like this happened,
and this is something that could happen
to me as well that happened in my own
family.
So on that level,
I do identify with,
uh,
the sort of,
you know,
what a lot of Muslims are going through.
On the other hand,
I also got a prejudice.
I mean,
I guess apostates get it from not only
the people who target Muslims,
but the Muslims who target a oscillates.
Uh,
so it's a bit of a double whammy there,
but yeah,
so you do relate to it.
And this,
it's a very complicated thing when you
have that mixture of ideology and
identity is,
it's a very complicated thing to
navigate and it's not as binary as
simple as you know,
what you hear when you hear someone like
Glenn Greenwald talk about,
or someone like Donald trump talk about
her do I think are sort of very similar.
Yeah.
Well that's why I phrased the question
the way I did because I don't see an
inherent contradiction there.
I think that everything that you've
described sounds completely feasible to
me in it.
And if anything,
it's not just feasible.
It sounds preferable to me because
you're taking the logical and the uh,
and the secular side of your,
of your existence and fully
acknowledging that and then also
acknowledging your,
your history and your family and all
that.
So that,
to me,
that to me makes full sense and more
people should be trying to do that.
Yeah,
I think there is a Phillips Zuckerman.
Is this,
he's a writer who wrote a book called,
I think it's called living the secular
life.
Um,
yeah,
I'm pretty sure that's what it's called
and that he actually talks about
secularizing religion.
He also did an interview with Sam
Harris.
Sam Harris interviewed him for his blog
and he talks about that as a very sort
of seminal step in moving towards
secularism is that,
you know,
you take,
you take the holidays and take the
rituals you take that,
the community aspect of it,
how they have Sunday assemblies and
everything.
Um,
so those are examples of things that
people can do and how,
you know,
religious actually move towards
secularism when you talked about reform
Judaism,
which was,
which is interesting because,
you know,
Judaism and Islam,
again,
very similar,
you know,
how God revealed the Chron directly to
Muhammad in the same way God supposedly
revealed the Torah to um,
uh,
to Moses at the Tabernacle and Mount
Sinai and so on.
And it was considered the literal word
of God.
It was actually considered the blueprint
for creation in genesis at one point.
So it was meant to even predate
creation.
And that's how it was thought of at a
time.
And then in the late,
late 18th,
I think it was the,
it was the 19th century,
early 19th century when the reform
Judaism movement really took hold in it,
it got demoted from literal word of God
to divinely inspired,
suddenly something that was written by
the hands of human beings.
And,
um,
revelation became a progressive thing,
you know,
so it was a quality.
They adopted a lot of secular values and
so on and,
and it changed.
So when people say,
well,
the Koran is infallible,
you know,
how are you going to change it?
And I always think thinking good,
the Koran,
there's precedent for that.
There's actually precedent for that.
Would Judaism,
uh,
with the Catholicism for instance,
I mean,
there's a lot of Catholics who approach
choice.
A lot of them practice birth control.
Many of them,
they fornicated to their heart's
content,
but you know,
you still go and they observe lent and
they celebrate Christmas and Easter.
Nobody kicks them out of the church
saying,
you know,
you're not a catholic.
Yeah.
Well,
for the record,
I told this to Peter last week,
but I actually went to Mount Sinai in
1997.
I went to Egypt,
I went to Sinai,
I hiked the mountain and literally
nothing happened.
I asked.
I mean,
I really did.
I was at that place in life,
uh,
you know,
20 or 21 or so,
or 19 and I,
I went there trying to have some thing
and talk to somebody and,
and nobody,
nobody talked back.
Bad experience the first time.
You don't want to repeat it again.
You don't.
Alright.
So I want to end with this because you
have brought up a phrase that I think
you hashtagged and I want to make sure
that when this thing takes off that
you're fully credited for it and
hopefully I'll have a little something
to do with it.
But you've talked about the new center
and I think it's the right phrase for
what we've been looking for.
I think it fits,
it fits because we have this left right
paradigm,
but it also fits the center of this
liberal split between,
you know,
the regressives and the say classic
liberals.
So can you just tell me a little bit
more about what you think the new center
is and what we can all do to,
to get people there?
Well,
it's basically what I described here
when it comes to purely this aspect of
Islam,
Islam and jihadism and sort of religious
extremism of,
even though that's a misnomer,
um,
it's,
it's about separating ideology from
identity.
It's about being able to stand up for
the rights of people,
but at the same time challenge ideas
when you attack and challenge ideas.
That's how society has moved forward.
A few attack and Dbas people.
That's what splits people out.
That's what actually rips us apart.
So being able to do,
to make that distinction is very
important.
I don't think either side is doing it
here.
I think that the center is more rational
and on a,
on a,
on a broader level too.
I've always found it bizarre that,
you know,
if you're fiscally conservative and then
you suddenly you have to be prolife why
does all of that go together?
I think it's absolutely ridiculous.
People should be able to have different,
uh,
you know,
I should be able to think that,
okay,
I believe in these fiscally conservative
principles,
time I'm socially liberal or I could
have libertarian presented,
but there's no rational.
I don't think you can be a rational
thinking person and be aligned with one
side or the other.
Well,
that's a whole other topic.
Figuring out how the politicians figured
out to make everything a wedge issue.
So somehow gay rights if you were for
gay rights,
you are also for,
you know,
low taxes,
like it just doesn't make any sense.
Um,
do you think there's any chance for a
political movement with that?
Because when you,
I saw it,
you did Hashtag new center and I thought
maybe there's politics.
They're not just not just this sort of
internal,
a discussion that will all have and
hopefully get it out there more.
But actually this could maybe be a
political movement.
I would like that.
And that's why I brought up the whole
fiscally conservative socially liberal
thing is because,
um,
when,
when I grew up on tv,
you had the 6:00
news and the 11:00
news and you know,
you saw everybody watched that,
whether you're liberal or Conservative,
I mean 1984 and Ronald Reagan won.
I mean,
he won California.
He won 49 states out of 50.
I'm not endorsing Ronald Reagan or
seeing anything against him either,
but I,
what I'm saying is that things weren't
as polarized.
You're going to later on,
you had 24 hour cable news,
so you had Fox News on one side and
Msnbc on the other and everybody just
watched what their own echo chamber was.
I mean,
it'll be every channel had its own echo
chamber with the blogosphere and with
the Internet that became even more
pronounced.
So there's a lot of polarization and I
think it's getting to a point and we're
seeing this with the regressive less
than I left on the trompe and right.
Um,
uh,
you know,
I think that there is that kind of
polarization is something that a lot of
reasonable rational,
uh,
people are not feeling.
It's not working for them,
they're actually frustrated by it and I
really hope that they do.
They're okay to let go of the
traditional left and right labels
because I practically meaningless right
now.
I don't think they mean anything.
Yeah,
just be human beings thinking human
beings.
I love that.
Perfect ending and I love the fact that
we've connected and you'll always have
an ally over here.
So next time,
hopefully we can do this in person when
you make it out to Los Angeles.
So I want to thank Ali Rizvi.
His book comes out next year,
but in the meantime,
you can follow his regressive smack
downs on twitter.
Thank you guys for watching and we'll
see you next time.